Hey, Jess.
Really nice job
helping them with the data structure.
>> Yeah, so we wanted to create a word
class that has both translations for
the English and Miwok of the same word.
>> And this is like the floor plan or
the blueprint analogy we
used in the last course.
>> Exactly.
And so from the same fore-plan,
we could create many
different word objects.
>> Okay.
[SOUND] Like this.
This is a word object which
represents the number one.
And inside the word object we
have two string variables.
A string variable for Miwok translation
which is luti, and a string variable for
the English translation which is one.
>> And because this word object
was created from this word class,
it's going to have these two methods.
So, the getMiwokTranslation method.
>> Which will translate this string.
>> And getDefaultTranslation method.
Okay, cool.
That sounds good.
>> All right, so from the same
fore-plan, we can create more and
more words.
So a word for two and a word for three.
>> My gosh, how many words objects?
>> All right, so in the next class,
we're going to take a look at how
to write this class definition.
>> Word.
>> Or if you need help you can refer to
the simplified version of the TextView
class that we showed
you in the last course.
So, remember that we need to provide
a constructor for your word class.
And the constructor just looks like
a method declaration, but the name of
the method has to match exactly the name
of the class, capitalization and all.
So in this case, we have the capital
T for text and capital V for
view with no spaces, which matches
exactly the name of the class TextView.
Also notice that the constructor
has no return type.
Now looking more closely at
the constructor for the TextView class,
we see it has the public keyword here.
And this public keyword says that
an outside class can access this
constructor.
So for example,
an outside color like the MainActivity
can call this constructor
using the new keyword and
pass in this input parameter to
create a new TextView object.
So note that you can create
multiple different constructors for
your class that have
different input parameters.
That way any outside color can create
a TextView object in a number of
different ways depending on what
input parameters they can provide.
Now in the next lesson,
we'll see firsthand how you can create
multiple constructors for a class.
So as mentioned earlier,
these private and
public words are called
access variables.
We first learned about
this in the last course.
So they define who has access to
these methods or constructors or
even this entire class.
If a method is marked private,
then it can only be called
within the enclosing class.
So if something is marked public, it
can be accessed from outside the class.
So if the MainActivity wants
to create a new text object,
then it can because this
class is marked as public.
And it also has a public constructor.
And if any of these variables or
methods here are public,
then the MainActivity can
call on those as well.
All right, so here's a diagram from
the last course if you remember.
If a TextView method
is marked as public,
we can access it from both within
the TextView class or from outside.
So something like
the MainActivity could access it.
In general, it's better to make
the variables of the app, so
those that control the state
of the object, to be private.
This way you can expose
the public methods that modify or
access these variables.
So these methods are called getter and
setter methods.
And they give you tighter control over
how these variables are modified or
accessed.
So for example, if these state
variables were marked as public,
someone could set it invalid
color value on the TextView.
And this would cause an unexpected
behavior in your class and
maybe even cause your app to crash.
Now in the other hand,
if you have a private color variable
with a public setter method,
you can check that the incoming color
is valid before updating the state.
Now, go ahead and move on to the quiz
where you'll create the word class.